it is in a word unfair
these are municipal workers in the town
of harkev ukraine their job on this day
to recover the remains of a 96 year old
man in his apartment
he was home friday when the building was
hit by shelling in a war started by
russia with an alleged mission to
denazify ukraine
russian troops killed a man who knew the
horrors of actual nazis
later in life he worked with a group
documenting nazi crimes
ukraine's president paid tribute to
romanchenko monday asking his country to
remember how many things romanchenko had
been through and survived
now at the time of the attack
romanchenko's neighbor was home as well
there was terrible shelling he says it
wasn't a bam more of a whistle three
terrible whistles
now the building may be uninhabitable
but some have no other options harkive
still faces russian shelling
this woman says she's alone and on a
pension there's nowhere else to go when
she's asked how she lives without water
or light
she says there's water coming in through
the room
what are believed to be romanchenko's
remains were taken to the local moor
ukraine's foreign minister is calling
his death an unspeakable crime writing
on twitter romanchenko survived hitler
but was murdered by putin
mike armstrong global news cheshire
poland